[Music]
I find
myself I grew up in a very, very poor family
I no longer remember toys
[Music]
we worked a lot in the fields
we had to do
[Music]
[Applause
] when I was 10 years old I started  to
work
and my mom wants me this time you're not going
to school because you have to take care of
my brothers
[Music]
because I didn't go to school
I remember I saved enough to
buy earrings, a ring and
shoes  I let myself have at least two pairs of shoes
I would like to have everything 34 or something like that
and at the age of 14 I left for the capital city
and I had a friend
supposedly he was a friend
I considered him to be a friend I never
imagined that he would do something like that to me
making an effort to do something,
what happened to me is getting
pregnant right
and from then on it got lost
and then when I came to tell my
parents
they didn't accept
me they kicked me out of the house
and I left
the people told me you can contribute
and I wanted to
go.  to  I'm going to have it
[Music]
the pink truth I've known her for 8
years she had her daughter with a
disability she had hydrocephalus
[Music]
looking for help everywhere
I travel to the cell I went to the best
specialists
they operated on me three times
and I  I was there washing his wound
and there, as there was already a change,
he began to react, he began to grab
his toys and it was a very, very
happy moment for me to see
once a lady told me that she is not
ashamed to take her daughter out on the streets
and I told her that I wasn't ashamed,
I wasn't very proud of her, she
was in my arms for two years and
nine months
[Music]
I always said I'm going to give her the studio
and she's never going to stay that way,
no matter how they make you feel  Alone
and goodbye
I see a lot of need in the community
I want to help
here in the community there is no
medical facility
that people had to leave their
cell phones to inject some medicine
I am going to graduate from
professional nursing in
El Mirador
and put a  The pharmacy is so bad that we
need it in the community,
what is coming for Rosa is difficult because they
wanted the women to get
ahead and the women stayed at
home cooking.
]
is that we as people
[Music]
be like birds
even though there are storms and
winds
[Music]
they never give up
we should not be afraid of those
storms but we
should have wings
and fly
[  Music]
[Music]
as it says in the phrase
we are going to need something else,
dreaming does not cost anything
[Music]
but putting it into practice
does cost
[Music]
and water
that is
[Music]
[  Music]